hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger by d'un musée d'ayew
pas la place et d'ail
[Musique]
là c'est à fait noir tue pas te rend
bien les fourrages ap j'avoue là c'est
beau monde au magic sur un jury a
conservé te feras quoi j'ai le goût de
vanille
certes un peu plombé
les petits pas qui je vais pas commencer
conclut sa maison à double manche de
base et relations attention la pièce la
mort il à s'apprécier montrent le besoin
à tout moment je peux pas faire
attention parce qu est ce qu elle me
ment lima ce cas précis revanche al jala
[Musique]
justement on va la reprendre
on a tout fait j'aime vous allez manger
de l'hélium
non je suis super bien on sélénium c'est
quoi cette voie à je peux la faire on va
repartir avec jean mi
est ce que l on va la paire adopte un
peu trop colérique ça je veux tellement
content de voir si ça fait plaisir
merci beaucoup merci maïs trop régler
tirer boîte c'est des gens à qui sont
pour les floute là c'est qu'ils font des
reportages où le bizarre vous pouvez
essayer de la chanter l'octave du tube à
heathrow et participe au scénario trop
vite ou tu te dis là c'est d'ailleurs
et là c'est un tout le froid jacoulot
ces paroles de boutiques sur un génie
pascal effet te frotte pas j'ai le goût
de vanille sur taper tout bronzé le bbc
pas le tube qui quand j'y vais pas
commencer on peut sans baisse d'un ton à
tout moment je peux passer à l'action
attention pas de questions calmement il
a sans pression pompe le son qui pèse
d'un fonds à tout moment ce que tu vas
faire là dessus
attention pas question calmement il a
précieusement geagea le lacet die die
die chez mes parents
bye bye bye zhihua
là c'est aïda
j'vais bye bye bye ziouani
et là c'est un gentil la cena
douch est là c'est un
lassé taille vous allez faire leur a
tout bon c'est la crise
ça va vite et l'ami soleil la fête
tissot la la la j'écoutais solana tu es
là tu ton là dans le numéro 10 oh là là
là à tulle qui volent à la la mais sa
part dans mon dos pop s'user paix on
transforme assez mais tu regardes tags
de piste à leur faisait colmater au lac
et al sanabel j'ai juste dit ce qui fait
qu'ils perdraient plane persico ne joue
pas pour tenter bluffé échangera et
jeanne mas et die die de genève et bye
bye bye bye bye
jason la médaille
ayvaz
oh
ce pas
seconde la menace est un
la sepa
ce nas et 1